And is there something that I can do to make the right machine quiet?
Not really, unless you can move the generator further away from you or you can tuck the generator under your bed.
Do not put the generator underneath a blanket or wrap it tightly.
The generator needs to be able to have room to breathe so that it does not overheat and blow the circuitry or blow a fuse.
But if you're having the generator up near your head, you could be peering that and then as far as the bulb goes, you can probably move it down by your feet.
If you have a grounding sheet on the bed, then I would recommend switching positions of the grounding sheet versus the bulb move the bulb down to your feet and move the grounding sheet up by the head of the bed.
That allows the right frequencies to fully move through your body before they may be pulled out through the grounding sheet.
Otherwise, if the bulb is too noisy for you, because sometimes the generator is what's making noise other times it's the bulb that actually seems to make the noise.
And then with the the flashing of the light that can be disruptive to people's sleep, you can go ahead and move that bulb down by your feet, just don't let it get completely buried underneath the covers because that will include the hole that is in the tubing that helps to release heat.
And that bulb can get hot enough that it can actually melt the plastic encasement that's around it.
So you just want to be mindful of that and make sure that you're giving the bulb room to breathe and that you're giving the generator room to breathe as well.
But most patients who struggle with the sound will tuck the bulb down by their feet and tuck the generator underneath their bed.